en este vídeo vamos a obtener un poco
más de práctica resolviendo unas
ecuaciones y bueno vamos a ver unas
ecuaciones que son un poquito más
complicadas que a lo que estamos
acostumbrados y van a tener puntos
decimales o fracciones por ejemplo
empezamos con la ecuación 1.2 por c
igual a 0.6 así es que estamos buscando
por qué número tengo que multiplicar a
1.2 para que nos quede 0.6 y la
respuesta lo más probable es que nos
salte a tu mente pero afortunadamente
podemos atacar este problema de una
forma más metódica y lo que a mí me
gusta hacer es fijarme en que la c que
es lo que estamos buscando cuánto vale
la c está del lado izquierdo y
simplemente se está multiplicando por
1.2 que dejamos pongo bien en este punto
decimal
pero algo que estaría muy bien es que la
c estuviera solita del lado izquierdo
del igual
porque de esa forma ya sabríamos
exactamente cuánto vale c entonces qué
es lo que puedo hacer para que nos quede
la sedesol y está del lado izquierdo del
igual pues una cosa que puedo hacer es
dividir entre 1.2 pero como hemos visto
ya varias veces uno no puede simplemente
dividir un solo lado de la igualdad
entre 1.2 porque se modificaría la
igualdad y este lado ya no sería igual a
este otro así es que si queremos dividir
entre 1.2 el lado izquierdo también
tenemos que dividir entre 1.2 del otro
lado y entonces del lado izquierdo
nos queda simplemente una c
y nos queda que la c es igual a 0.6 0.6
entre 1.2 1.2 y bueno esto a cuanto es
igual y en estos momentos a mí lo que me
gusta hacer es decir oye porque no
tratamos de deshacernos de estos puntos
decimales y para hacer eso pues hay que
multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por un número
suficientemente grande como para que el
punto decimal desaparezca y
qué es lo que pasa si multiplicamos
tanto el numerador como el denominador
por
a ver pensemos qué pasa si los
multiplicamos por 10 y si multiplicamos
el numerador por 10 nos va a quedar
simplemente 6 y si multiplicamos el
denominador por 10 nos va a quedar 12
así es que pues vamos a hacer eso aunque
ahí vamos a multiplicar por 10 el
numerador y el denominador y como
seguramente recuerdas justo como estamos
multiplicando tanto al numerador como el
denominador por exactamente el mismo
número entonces no estamos afectando el
valor de la fracción porque esto es como
multiplicar por 1 y lo que nos queda es
que 0.6 por 10-6
y 1.2 por diez son 12-13 es igual a 6
entre 12 ahora si queremos simplificar
esta fracción simplemente tenemos que
dividir tanto el numerador como el
denominador entre 6
6 entre 61 y
y 12 entre 6 estos ahora si regresamos a
la ecuación original pues aquí podemos
ver esto como que tenemos 12 décimos por
c y de este lado tenemos 6 decimos
entonces pues puede ser bastante claro
que se tiene que ser igual a un medio
bueno ahora hagamos otro ejercicio
digamos que tenemos que un cuarto es
igual h sobre el 12 y en esta ecuación
lo que queremos hacer es encontrar el
valor de ye yé se encuentra del lado
derecho del igual pero se encuentra
dividido entre 12 en si es que cuál es
la mejor forma de dejar a la g solita
bueno pues para deshacernos de este
entre 12 y dejar alayes solita del lado
derecho del igual podemos multiplicar a
los dos lados por 12
si multiplicó al lado derecho por 12
también tengo que multiplicar al lado
izquierdo por 12 y otra vez porque
escogí el 12 porque estamos
multiplicando por 12 por aquí
bueno pues estábamos buscando un número
por el cual multiplicar este lado para
que nos quede la aie solita y si
multiplicamos por 12 12 entre 12 es un 1
y nos queda simplemente la jr
este se cancela con este y del lado
izquierdo pues nos queda 12 por un
cuarto pero 12 por un cuarto es 12
cuartos entonces entre 4 y del lado
derecho nos queda simplemente ya y
podemos reordenar esto podemos ponerla y
del lado izquierdo lo que tenemos que sí
es igual a 12 entre 4 y lo único que
hice fue cambiarlos de lugar y a cuánto
es igual 12 cuartos pues lo podemos ver
como 12 entre 4 y 12 entre 4 estrés o
también lo podemos ver como 12 cuartos y
12 cuartos son literalmente tres enteros
entonces doce cuartos es igual a tres
que es igual a tres y de hecho lo
podemos revisar en la ecuación original
un cuarto si es igual a 312 abós ok
porque la aie es igual a 3 esa es una de
las cosas más padres de las ecuaciones y
es que siempre puedes revisar que tengas
la respuesta correcta vamos con otro
ejercicio no podemos detenernos verdad
bueno digamos que 4.5 es igual a 0.5 por
n
aquí en esta ecuación queremos saber
cuánto vale n
y bueno la tenemos del lado derecho pero
se está multiplicando por 0.5 y nos
gustaría tenerla solita y qué puedo
hacer para que eso suceda bueno pues
puedo dividir ambos lados de él igual
entre 0.5 porque ahí vamos a dividir
entre 0.5 y todo lo que haga con el lado
derecho se lo tengo que hacer al lado
izquierdo también aunque tenemos que
dividir entre 0.5 y porque estoy
dividiendo entre 0.5 bueno pues para que
de este lado nos quede simplemente una n
que nos queda del lado izquierdo pues
nos queda 4.5 entre
0.5 y del lado derecho pues nos queda
simplemente n aunque porque esto se
cancelan nos queda n
así es que cuánto vale n pues n es igual
a 4.5 entre 0.5 y bueno pues hay varias
formas de simplificar esto por ejemplo
podemos pensar aquí que tenemos 45
decímetros y por acá tenemos 5 décimas
lo cual nos dice que esto es igual a 9 o
bueno si esto sonó demasiado complicado
podemos hacerlo paso por paso lo que
podemos hacer lo mismo que hicimos por
acá osea multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por un número que nos ayude
a quitar el punto decimal y ese número
es 10 en este caso vamos a multiplicar
por 10 ok
porque eso hace que se recorra el punto
decimal un lugar hacia la derecha
y podemos hacer esto porque en realidad
10 entre 10 es uno entonces estamos
multiplicando por 1 y nos queda
exactamente lo que teníamos así es que
si multiplicamos el numerador y el
denominador por 10 de esta forma no
estamos cambiando el valor de la
fracción así es que nos queda que 45
entre 5 es igual a n y bueno justo en
este momento tú puedes decir oye oye sal
espera un momento tú nos acabas de decir
que todo lo que le hagamos al lado
izquierdo del igual también se lo
tenemos que hacer al lado derecho y
ahorita acabas de multiplicar por esta
fracción únicamente del lado izquierdo y
no del lado derecho entonces qué está
pasando aquí y bueno este es el momento
en el que tienes que recordar que 10
entre 10 es un 1 y que el multiplicar
por 1 no cambia el valor de la fracción
aunque de hecho si quieres podemos
multiplicar de este lado también por 10
entre 10 pero pues 10 entre 10 es 11 y
entonces no estamos cambiando el valor
de n
lo que nos queda simplemente en otra vez
cuando multiplicamos por 10 entre 10 no
estamos cambiando estos valores
simplemente estamos multiplicando por un
1 de una forma muy creativa para
escribir esta fracción de otra forma
aunque tenga exactamente el mismo valor
ok entonces cuando multiplicó por 10
entre 10
no estoy echando a perder la regla de
que todo lo que le haga al lado
izquierdo se lo tengo que hacer al lado
derecho es solo que cuando multiplicamos
por un 1 como no estamos cambiando el
valor podemos simplemente no expresar
que estamos multiplicando por 1
lo mismo que cuando sumas un cero o
cuando restas un cero no necesariamente
tienes que mostrar del otro lado del
igual que está sumando o restando un
cero justo porque no cambian el valor en
fin 45 entre 59 y entonces n es igual a
9 y lo podemos checar en la ecuación
original 4.5 es igual a 0.5 por 9 pues
sí porque la mitad de 9 si es 4.5 en fin
hagamos uno más pero pues vamos a
dividir
el espacio de trabajo a ver vamos a
poner una variable distinta que te
parece una g g entre 4 es igual a 3.2 a
ver lo que quiero hacer en esta ecuación
es deshacerme de este entre 4 para poder
encontrar fácilmente el valor de g y lo
primero que se me ocurre es multiplicar
por 4 aunque pero hay que hacerlo de los
dos lados y porque estoy multiplicando
por cuatro pues porque éste se cancela
con este y nos queda simplemente una g
que nos queda una g
y de este lado tenemos 3 puntos 2 por 4
3 por 4 es 12 y por aquí tenemos dos
décimas 1.2 y 2 por 4 es 8 entonces nos
quedan ocho décimas no se apuntó ocho
que es igual a 12.8 y lo podemos
verificar en la ecuación de 12.8 entre 4
es igual a 3.2